I think the most fun I've had working
out social change initiative was it was
around Christmas several years ago and
back to two thousand one after September
eleventh and I was working for the
American Medical Association their
public health division and the networks
had a ban against hard liquor ads and
and what the reason was to protect
children and at the sort of the last
minute they sent out a press release
saying they were going to go back and BC
was going to go back on a voluntary ban
and we knew we had to do something so a
middle of night we thought okay we
better put out a full-page ad in The New
York Times and say look morning parents
watching NBC may be hazardous to your
children's health and like within 72
hours NBC reversed their decision so and
it was the largest advertising deal in
the history of television so in terms of
like having fun and having impacts that
was probably it well Hillary Clinton's
presidency has forever changed the way
every woman sees herself I mean any
woman could get up and see herself at
least from a gender perspective as being
a serious contender for president you
know several years ago I ran for
president and a showtime reality series
called American candidate and I made it
my job to go out and shake hands with
all these little girls and say hey look
are you thinking about running for
office someday or being president and
they said yes in droves and I was a fake
presidential candidate so I can't
imagine what she's done for the future
girls of this country
you